okay in this lesson we're going to talk
about the pythagorean theorem and
pythagorean triples so just a refresher
when you have a right triangle okay the
two sides that make up the right angle
those are called the legs or the sides
of the triangle and the side that's
across from the right angle that's the
hypotenuse that's called c we have a
formula a squared plus b squared equals
c squared so the sum of the
leg squared equals the hypotenuse
squared and the pythagorean triples are
ones that come up oftentimes on the act
because they're they're easy to work
with and they're it's also a time saver
if you know these ones by by memory so
basically if the two legs were three and
four automatically know the hypotenuse
is five or if you knew that one of the
legs is three and the hypotenuse is five
then you know the other leg is 4. so
these are common ones that come up a lot
it's definitely
useful to memorize those and the other
thing too is that you can recognize is
that multiples of these are also going
to be right triangles so if i saw like a
6 8 i would automatically know that the
missing side here is going to be 10. all
i did was double all those so if you can
recognize that it's a multiple of one of
the pythagorean triples as well that
again is just a time saver but you don't
have to know that you can always just go
back to the pythagorean theorem and
solve for the missing the missing side
so let's go through a couple examples
and get some practice see if you can do
these on your own and we'll go through
them together so this first example
you know a person's flying a kite let's
just say that they're standing on the
string here okay with their foot and
here's the kite
they let out 130 feet of string uh it's
120 feet okay horizontally to below the
kite and we're trying to find the height
of the kite so how would you do a
problem like that
okay so what we could do is we could
just do the pythagorean theorem we could
say a squared
plus b squared
equals
c squared
and then all we have to do is say x
squared equals 130 squared minus 120
squared and then just take the square
root of both sides after we simplify and
that's going to be
the height but an easier way to do this
problem if we recognize c 12
13 it looks like this pythagorean triple
right here this side must be 5 but you
can see these have been multiplied by 10
so this height is going to be 50. so
it's a little bit of a shortcut you can
see it's 50 feet above the ground okay
let's try example number two now this
one's just more straightforward but just
to practice
they're giving you the two legs and
you're solving for the hypotenuse so how
would you do that one
well let's see we've got a squared
plus b squared
equals c squared so this is 36 plus 100
equals x squared we have 136 equals x
squared we take the square root of both
sides and you want to be able to
simplify these radicals so let's see if
we can break down 136 so i'm just going
to go to my calculator real quick
let's see half of 136
is let's see 68. so we've got 68 times 2
we've got 34 times 2 we have 2 times 17
and when you're taking the square root
you know you're looking for a pair of
the same
quantity so we have a pair of 2's that's
4 the square root of 4 is 2
and then we have a 17 times 2 left over
so that's
2 square root of 34. so you can either
get a exact answer like this or you
could do your just get a decimal
approximation so the square root of 136
would be about 11.7
is this length right here
so definitely pythagorean theorem is
important to know for the act and again
a little shortcut here with the
pythagorean triples